Just to touch upon some Unreal Engine resources, we have two main places to go for the topics
here which is the Learning Library and the Epic Games Launcher.
The Learning Management System is a recent addition and here you can follow a guided
learning path.
There's plenty of content here to dig into and it's also connected to the community which
is great because you can get feedback on certain information you might need.
You can also learn from industry experts here, so people will be putting tutorials
and project samples down here so you can pull them apart and learn for yourself.
It can also test your knowledge so you can complete the courses and just upskilling the
areas that you need to.
And you can also build a learner profile used for the same login on the Unreal Engine Launcher
which I'll get into in a second but it's a really nice centralized place for your learning
resources here.
And then the Epic Games Launcher, so you can learn about upcoming features, you can see
the live streams that are currently happening.
We've got featured content that might inspire some of your projects.
You can access the Marketplace from here which is a tab at the top of the Launcher there
in the middle section of the tabs.
You can install engine updates so get the latest version of the Unreal Engine and you
can also access your Marketplace downloads from here for use in your own projects.